hallo leute heute wollen wir mal mit
euch einen kleinen blick hinter die
kulissen unseres easy german podcasts
werfen
wie ihr vielleicht wisst produzieren wir
schon seit über sechs monaten einen
podcast bei isar germany darin
unterhalte ich mich mit manuell und
einigen weiteren gästen über deutschland
über alles was man wissen muss wenn man
nach deutschland zieht und auch über
unser alltägliches leben und dieses
alltägliche leben verändert sich jetzt
gerade wir alle sind jetzt viel zu hause
wir können nicht mehr rausgehen und in
dieser zeit haben wir uns entschieden
dass wir noch mehr podcasten es gibt
immer noch jede woche unseren regulären
podcast der kommt am dienstag heraus und
da gibt es auch ein transkript und eine
vokabel hilfe für unsere mitglieder
damit man live mitlesen kann und die
vokabeln auch übersetzen kann und
zusätzlich nehmen wir jetzt seit letzter
woche auch ein tägliches format auf und
das nennen wir das zwischending und in
diesem täglichen format da sprechen wir
eben darüber was gerade in unserem leben
passiert und wie sich die welt um uns
herum verändert und das möchten wir
heute mal zeigen denn normalerweise hört
er uns nur ihr seht uns nicht und wir
dachten heute ist mal eine gute
gelegenheit um ihr euch erstens davon zu
erzählen dass es jetzt mehr podcast gibt
im moment bei isar germany und euch mal
zu zeigen wie das aussieht
los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hayek ari emanuel gutes timing meine
nachbarin oben hat gerade angefangen mit
dem geigen und gesangsunterricht es
könnte eine musikalische folge werden
heute
[Musik]
zwischending hallo manuel hallo karin
ganz ungewohnt heute ja normalerweise
sehen wir uns nicht aber wir machen ja
heute einen podcast der gleichzeitig ein
video ist und deswegen sehen wir uns
ausnahmsweise mal was für eine verrückte
idee hat normalerweise vorteile dass wir
uns nicht sehen dann können wir mal
morgens noch im schlafanzug aufnehmen
richtig es ist eine eine der wenigen
episoden wo ich gewusst habe
vor der aufnahme haben wir auch mal ein
bisschen hat einen positiven einfluss
auf unseren tagesablauf
ja es ist heute mittwoch der erste april
ist ist 11 uhr 30 und wir haben jetzt
zwei tage nicht gecastet manuel und ich
bin jetzt richtig wieder frisch ich habe
richtig lust auf podcasten das ist gut
du auch ich auch und ich habe wie immer
eine merkel anekdote also wie fast immer
mittlerweile an actor und eine anekdote
von angela merkel mitgebracht sind wir
jetzt hier die merkelsche oder was so
ein bisschen oder werden in der letzten
episode eine anekdote gehabt davor auch
schon
ja und zwar ja ich habe nämlich auch
noch eine okay willst du zuerst war ich
zuerst du okay also im moment ist es ja
so wenn aufgrund der korona krise gibt
es ganz viele so wichtige bereiche die
richtig gefährdet da sind dadurch sind
zum beispiel wenn in einer feuerwehr
mannschaft sich einer infiziert dann
muss im grunde die ganze mannschaft
unter quarantäne gestellt werden weil
die ja dann alle hochrisiko sind und
dann können die nicht mehr einsätze
fahren und auf der insel rügen eine
kleine insel hast du die erreichen
nachricht gelesen hast du dir auch
gelesen eine kleine insel in deutschland
dort hat sich die freiwillige feuerwehr
freiwillig in quarantäne begeben also im
selbstisolation also auch von ihren
familien also die verbringen
sie hat ihre gesamte zeit auf der wache
damit sich auf keinen fall jemand an
steckt damit sie auf jeden fall weiter
ausdrücken können so und das fand eine
jacke an schön krass und das fand unsere
bundeskanzlerin die er auch in der
isolation ist im moment so toll dass sie
sich gedacht hat da rufe ich mal an und
bedanke mich bei der mannschaft und es
war aber auch noch so dass das ihr
wahlkreis ist also harry hahn stimmt aus
der region und deswegen als politiker
ist mein angela merkel könnte
theoretisch das egal sein dies jetzt
bundeskanzlerin aber man hat natürlich
eine verbindung zum wahlkreis das sind
ja die leute im besten fall die einen
auch direkt wählen können und da hat man
dann noch mal ein bisschen richtig
sitzung dazu sie ist da richtig
abgeordnete noch in diesem sehr
wahlkreis so und jetzt ruft sie da an um
sich zu bedanken
und es gibt in deutschland super viele
so radioshows die senatoren haben es
gibt super viele merkel imitatoren die
die stimme so nachmachen und die dann
irgendwelche scherzanrufe machen und
jetzt dachte der typ von der feuerwehr
das ist sicher irgendeine radiosender
der uns verarschen will und hat einfach
aufgelegt und ja und dann hat das büro
von der kanzlerin angerufene gesagt also
dass jetzt tatsächlich die
bundeskanzlerin als wird es dann jetzt
gerne noch ein zweites mal versuchen
und beim zweiten mal hat es dann
geklappt weil das war schon ganz gute
geschichte schnell vor mehr gerufen und
übrigens dass eine verarsche ja also für
so etwas habe ich wirklich keine zeit
jetzt schüsse die branche eine eine
verarschung ist ein ja wenn man einen
scherz über eine person macht ja da war
gar keine verarsche war wirklich die
kanzlerin am apparat und jo
hallo hier spricht die bundeskanzlerin
wollte mal hallo sagen so scherz gemacht
aber ich kann das auch nicht nachmachen
ja ja so haben wir immer was zu erzählen
ja ich hatte ja die gleiche geschichte
maja doch doch getroffen
wir haben ja sonst nichts schönes
aufregendes aus
merkel geschichten merkel kaufte wein
merkel dinge machten podcast merkel ruft
bei der feuerwehr an und legt auf aber
ich wollte ich mal fragen wie es dir so
geht jetzt mit der ganzen geschichte mir
so aufgefallen dass ich jetzt so diese
diese corona zeit ich habe das gefühl
ich bin jetzt so dies jetzt so
angekommen in meinem alltag
ich habe mich ja eingelebt sozusagen in
meinen neuen alltag wie ist das bei dir
ich habe mich auch daran gewöhnt würde
ich sagen und ich bin daran gewöhnt viel
zu hause zu sein und für mich ist das
irgendwie völlig in ordnung aber
gleichzeitig habe ich voll oft so
momente wo ich mir einfach denke wie
krass also wie was wie krass was das
einfach für eine situation ist in der
wir gerade sind und n der die welt ist
und ich lese die nachrichten aus der
welt und habe manchmal so momente wo ich
mir wo ich dann auch in seiner
traurigkeit so ein bisschen verfall und
mir denke oh mein gott das ist gerade
richtig schlimm so das habe ich jetzt
diese woche zum ersten mal nicht mehr
und das finde ich ganz ruhig hatte so in
der ersten woche hatte ich diese
schockmomente immer noch dass ich
aufgewacht bin und da ein schöner
normaler tag und dann plötzlich
realisiert habe nein das ist kein
schöner normaler tag das ist
ausnahmezustand und in der zweiten woche
habe ich mich dann mehr darum war ich
eigentlich viel zu viel im stress und
habe mich darum gekümmert meinen alltag
und unsere arbeit neu zu strukturierende
also die videos zu produzieren ist jetzt
schwieriger geworden dafür machen wir
jetzt aber mehr podcast und das ist ja
auch eine schöne geschichte und viele
leute schreiben uns wir bekommen so
viele e mails wie nie zuvor
ja ja und diese woche habe ich das
gefühl jetzt jetzt wirklich angekommen
in dieser neuen realität ja das ist doch
gut ich habe noch ein thema mitgebracht
ja und zwar ein ich habe zwei themen
noch mitgebracht erst mal wollte ich dir
sagen ein follow up zum thema joan
oliver ich habe ja letzte woche
gemeckert dass der nicht auch mal zu
hause was produziert ich drück sehr
gerne joan oliver stone last week
tonight und er hat das jetzt ich wollte
das gerne mal verkünden weil dann ich
hab ja letzte woche gesagt dass er das
nicht hinbekommt zuhause zu produzieren
aber er hat hier zu hause eine show
produziert hast du dir gesehen ja ich
habe es tatsächlich schon gesehen und
ich muss man sagen das ist jetzt
wirklich die professionellste show von
all den amerikanischen late night haus
also rein produktionstechnisch weil ich
war ja überrascht dass die leute riesige
teams haben riesige studios und dann
sobald die technik nicht mehr da ist auf
sich allein gestellt sind und halt
eigentlich muss man dann halt dazu
übergehen was wir machen youtuber sein
und stellt eine kamera auf stellt sich
davor und redet halt da rein und das da
war ich doch überrascht dass das gar
nicht alle so gut können plötzlich oder
halt eben ja dann stephen colbert sitzt
dann da mit seinem handy mit seinem
iphone und redete seine airports und die
quali ist einfach so war schlecht und
joan oliver hat jetzt einig und die
haben ihm glaube ich equipment gebracht
hat so sein studio zu hause nachgebaut
und hat dann da aufgenommen und dann hat
er gestern hatte war nämlich bei steven
gold colbert zu gast digital und hat
erzählt wie er das gemacht hat und das
hat er sehr lustig erzählt der hat
nämlich erzählt er hatte dann auch einen
zoom call und in dem kol haben ihm dann
seine mitarbeiter genau erklärt wie er
diese dieses equipment an an aufbaut und
benutzt und er meinte er wäre
überfordert gewesen hässlich gefühlt wie
so ein flugzeug pilot also wie jemand
der noch nie flugzeug geflogen hat der
jetzt gerade
navigiert wird wie er den flug das
flugzeug landen muss sehr witziger
ausschnitt ich hab den mal hier ich will
verlinken den mal in den charts ja
manuel verfeuert noch die nachrichten
oder sagst du jetzt ist auch ich kann
mich nicht jeden tag mit den chancen
sachen doch doch ich bin news junkie und
was heißt da so auch wieder fallen in
letzten letzter zeit
das ist ein quiz ich irgendwas
spezifisch ist oder nein ich einfach ob
es irgendetwas gibt was dich so
beschäftigt sind oder ob sich die
nachrichten
nerven die gunsten es ist ja auch man
wird ja auch extrem geleitet von den
nachrichten also ich verfolgte es gerade
sehr stark die situation in den usa wo
sich die lage jetzt wirklich stündlich
irgendwie verändert und das ist
natürlich super heftig was da jetzt
gerade passiert und super interessant
gleichzeitig denke ich mir aber auch
irgendwie krass dass jetzt so viel
darüber berichtet wird und ich denke mir
es gibt so viele andere länder die jetzt
sich ja auch betroffen sind wo ich so
sehr wenig lese und höre aber ja die usa
stehen jetzt gerade so sehr im
vordergrund habe ich das gefühl new york
ja also in den deutschen nachrichten gar
nicht so sehr oder doch finde ich schon
okay ja weil das jetzt das meist
betroffene land ist gerade ja zumindest
mit den fällen er ich habe noch ein
follow up von jeden fall irgendwie ja
das ist richtig ausgesprochen 1 und
einer unserer zuhörer der und sehr oft
schreibt und das freut mich sehr und er
hat uns ein follow up geschickt zum
thema masken und wir haben da ja nur
kurz darüber geredet und ich finde dass
es so ein thema was irgendwie schwierig
ist weil dass diese diskussion findet
auf mehreren ebenen statt das gibt dann
einmal die gesetzliche ebene es gibt so
ein bisschen die private gesellschaft
gesellschaft nicht natürlich also in
deutschland wird gerade darüber
diskutiert ob man die masken
verpflichtend machen soll es gibt einige
länder die haben das schon es gibt
einige länder da ist das sowieso
passiert das ganz häufig und der hat mir
einen interessanten artikel geschickt
aus der nachgucken aus der south china
morning post
und da geht es darum wie das tragen von
masken kulturell verankert ist und das
ist etwas was wo ich mich noch nie so
großartig mit beschäftigt habe aber da
ist es das ist ganz interessant in dem
artikel wird erklärt warum das in vielen
asiatischen ländern ist das tragen von
masken schon gesundheitlich relevant
gewesen schon über eine längere zeit
weil es da eben zum beispiel saß und
mehr schon früher gab aber auch weil das
ein thema ist zum dass also der smog ist
sind viele
dann ein thema und das wird eben auch
als schutz vor dem smart benutzt aber es
hat auch eine kulturelle komponente
nämlich sind das meer kollektivistische
kulturen
das heißt es kommt mehr auf die masse an
und weniger auf das individuum während
deutschland oder die usa zum beispiel
sehr individualistisch sind und das hat
tatsächlich auch was damit zu tun warum
das bei uns nicht so kulturell
akzeptiert ist in deutschland oder warum
es zumindest noch ein bisschen längeren
widerstand gibt formen masken trägt ja
und ich glaube das könnte sich jetzt
wirklich ändern also ich glaube auch
dass wir jetzt hier immer noch an dem
punkt sind wo menschen die jetzt mit
einer maske rausgehen so ein bisschen
komisch angeschaut werden
dabei sind sie es ja eigentlich die die
anderen schützen also die masken
schützen ja mehr die anderen als ein
selbst und dass ich heute morgen auch
gelesen in jena sind jetzt schon masken
pflicht beim einkaufen und ich kann mir
vorstellen dass wenn dann so ein punkt
ist worauf einmal eine maske tragen dann
ändert sich das natürlich ganz schnell
glaube ich das glaube ich auch gestern
hast du gestern die tagesschau gesehen
oder die tagesthemen
da war es nämlich da hat man so ganz
krass gesehen wo die debatte in
deutschland gerade steht da wurde ein
virologe interviewt und der hat dann
erzählt warum er das für nicht sinnvoll
erachtet in deutschland eine masken
pflicht einzuführen und das hat gleich
mehrere gründe für ihn und ein grund ist
auch einfach logistisch dass man im
moment das nicht leisten kann dass jeder
eine maske zu hause hat ja und der hat
also quasi sich dagegen ausgesprochen
und direkt danach kam ein kommentar von
einer journalistin die sich dafür
ausgesprochen hat und das ist gerade so
der punkt wo die debatte in deutschland
steht
ich persönlich denke auch dass es jetzt
kommen wird es gibt auch ganz viele
initiativen da hat uns unser zuhörer
daniel auch einen ganz interessanten
link geschickt
die domain maske auf punkt.de da rufen
also verschiedene menschen auch viele
prominente dazu auf masken zu tragen und
es haben auch viele prominente
angefangen mit zu arbeiten selber masken
zu produzieren
ich habe mir gestern abend auch welche
bestellt von finn kliemann kennt zu den
jetzt ein deutscher musiker und youtuber
und der hat jetzt einen workshop so
umgebaut oder einfach über über seinen
workshop verkauft er jetzt fair
gehandelte und fair produzierte masken
zu einem fairen preis ganz interessant
also ja es ist ein das ist so ein weites
feld
und ich bin mir ein bisschen ja ich will
jetzt nicht sagen dass ich keine klare
meinung dazu habe aber ich finde das ist
noch interessant zu beobachten dass die
die meinung so weit auseinandergehen ich
glaube auch dass ich das einfach
irgendwann etablieren wird nämlich dann
wenn es masken gibt wenn die jetzt jeder
produziert und dann wenn es eben auch
wenn die meisten leute das einfach
tragen ich sehe auf der straße letzte
woche hat keiner eine maske getragen
wird sind das doch schon bestimmt 50
prozent ja und ich schätze nächste woche
wird das einfach mit werden die meisten
leute in die maske haben oder was denkst
du dass es so schnell geht glaube ich
nicht auch schon allein wegen der
verfügbarkeit also ich habe jetzt auch
schon mal geschaut und hab echt nicht so
spontan was gefunden wo man einfach
welche bestellen kann und dann denkt man
sich ja auch okay die krankenhäuser
brauchen die erst mal aber wenn die
verfügbarkeit da ist ich glaube schon
auch das dann wandel stattfinden wird
ich glaube aber dass es ein bisschen
länger dauern wird als eine woche
vielleicht aber schauen wir mal gut kari
manuel hat mich gefreut mich zu
quatschen und mich auch ihr liebe
zuhörer und zuschauer könnt uns auch
jeden tag zu hören nämlich wo manuel
germany punkt fm und dort findet man
alle links zu den apps wo man uns
abonnieren kann auch wie das
funktioniert mit der vokabel hilfe und
so weiter und so fort kann man dort
alles nachlesen
dann hören wir uns morgen wieder ja das
tun wir
das ist ankara
[Musik]